você sabe por que eu fico parado e
olhando pra vocês
a carência é verdade
todo escritor é carente na época o
escritor solitário ele fica ali em
frente à página em branco olhando para
ver se consegue tirar alguma frase então
no fundo ele tem uma carência ele chega
aqui no auditório desse lotado de uma
porção de gente aplaudindo
ele quer ficar aqui parado esperar que
as pessoas continuem explodindo né
porque nem a própria em prol de um livro
você já viu isso acontecer você pega um
livro você gosta adorou o livro é
colocar o lixo na mesa começa aplaudiu o
livro ninguém faz isso quando eu estava
no ensino médio tinha um amigo joão o
nome dele aí vem aquele negócio de teste
vocacional ea psicóloga perguntou pra
ele o que você quer sejam ele falou qual
é a profissão que tem mais aplausos
ela falou palhaço para eu quero ter isso
e ele é um ótimo palhaço hoje em dia
consegue ter o seu índice de sucesso
não sei se avisar a vocês nosso assunto
ao contrário nosso assunto é um fracasso
você sabe a diferença de fracasso
derrota não vamos confundir tá é derrota
quando você sai na night para uma balada
e aquela meia noite daniel mora uma
tremenda derrota você volta para casa
frustrado fracasso é muito pior para a
causa de pedir um projeto você gasta
tempo com ele e depois de gastar um
tempo você tenta executar e não consegue
fracasso é muito solitário fracasso que
leva uma tela negra quando você pensa
que vai aparecer alguma coisa
o fracasso não tem amigos
essa frase é do ex-presidente do
presidente jfk quando se referia o
fracasso não tem amigos ele queria falar
exatamente o que eu quero dizer a vocês
que o fracasso está recheado de solidão
diferentemente do sucesso como prestar
atenção nisso quando um projeto nosso
tem sucesso
o sucesso de todos que participaram
daquele projecto mas quando tem fracasso
o fracasso é só seu
o fracasso não tem amigos o fracasso
também é solitário
o sucesso a gente deve dividir com todos
fracasso deve assumir porque o fracasso
é só nós
eu tive muitos durante a vida continuo
tendo diariamente em quase todos os
projetos da minha vida eu fracassei mas
eu sigo fracassando de fracasso em
fracasso com muito entusiasmo o fracasso
com vontade o fracasso com força
eu volto a ele pra casar de novo com o
teimoso danado e volta para uma tela
preta
esse cara muda um pouco o nosso conceito
de fracassos na china não porque seria
muito fácil dizer pra vocês aqui olha o
que eu aprendi com o fracasso aliás é a
pergunta dessa palestra o que vocês
aprenderam com o fracasso é possível
aprender alguma coisa com o fracasso
esse senhor está aqui atrás
ali eu não vejo esse senhor ele muda o
nosso concelho fracasso você já viu
alguém fracassado no facebook fala sério
né
todo mundo tem sucesso no facebook eu
fico impressionado todo mundo parece o
rei da inglaterra
tá todo mundo em festa né tá todo mundo
com o iate carro tudo bem que têm os
carros roubados a populismos mas tá todo
mundo sempre feliz não no facebook a
rede social de quem tem fracasso eu
nunca vi ninguém postou a foto do
dentista self da minha cara o número
quatro que já viram isso ninguém possa
self dentista no facebook
o aplauso não vem de pé não existe
aplauso porque todo mundo está sendo
aplaudido o facebook muda essa nossa
noção e nos dá a falsa ilusão de que
todo mundo tem sucesso ninguém coloca os
seus fracassos ninhos de vídeo nas redes
sociais
isso era o que a gente deveria começar a
fazer a vida não é o que o nosso querido
mark zuckerberg traçou para nós
infelizmente que os fracassos são muito
mais presentes
é uma questão neurológica gente tristeza
não tem fim felicidade sim você já ouvir
esses versos esses versos definem que o
fracasso em fracasso são muito mais
importantes da nossa vida que o sucesso
se a gente pode aprender com os
fracassos não sei
o pessoal da autoajuda dizer que sim o
paulo coelho é ter orgasmos com isso ele
disse 'não tudo conspira para você você
vai aprender e vai ter sucesso e
fracasso em fracasso você terá acesso eu
não sei não sei mesmo
vou enganar vocês com isso estou vendo
essa figura e vêem vermelho só eu é é
aparece mas sou eu no ensino médio sabe
o cara que tá com champanhe lá em cima
do amigo joão que virou palhaço festinha
de final de ano final do ensino médio
ele está com champanha e olha para essa
foto e eu fico pensando acho que o
primeiro caminho para o fracasso é você
tem muitas expectativas e você pensar
como penso meu amigo joão embora ele
tenha conseguido que no final das contas
as pessoas vão te aplaudir e vou te
aplaudir de pé o jogo ele tinha um outro
sonho ele dizia o seguinte olha a minha
meta não é só ser aplaudido tem que ser
aplaudido no mínimo por 30 segundos
porque a prova com menos de 30 segundos
de aplauso gente é palminha então eu
quero ser um palhaço que vai ser
aplaudido e esse é um grande problema
o princípio do fracasso e ansiedade que
o fracasso fl é repleto de ansiedade
a gente sempre projeta aquilo que a
gente quer como recompensa e se você
parte de um projeto querendo a
recompensa
você começa errado a única maneira de
você acertar é saber que o o após o
verdadeiro aquele aplauso de pé
ele está presente na caminhada 1 e na
final não existe caminho existe só a
caminhada meus amigos não é o objetivo
que você tem que perseguir é a caminhada
para esse objetivo que se localiza o
aplauso do meu amigo do ano
aí vocês estão vendo quase todos os
livros que já publiquei na vida todos
eles um grande fracasso
eu nunca ganhei um prêmio jabuti foi
finalista duas vezes mas nunca me deram
o prêmio nunca merecer elogios da
crítica esse livrinho vermelho que está
na ponta é um livro sobre separações são
os meus fracassos amorosos ano do livro
é beijo na testa pior do que a separação
mas não é essa imagina meu marido está
latindo aquele beijo na testa de amor
escrita e outra feira
ninguém sai de casa dá um beijo na testa
né
livros sobre jornalismo escreveu três
romances escrever uma biografia
nenhum deles teve sucesso provavelmente
vocês nem sabem que o escritor não deve
ter uma pessoa aqui nesse auditório que
tenha lido um livro aliás quem lhe no
brasil se escritor é um trabalho
solitário que nos volta o nosso querido
hobbit que ante o fracasso não tem
amigos a gente vive na solidão
se bem que eu acho que ele quem deteve
muitos amigos não teve tudo bem tudo bem
não mas tudo mal uma morte trágica
mais uma morte trágica de um homem que
serviu o seu país mas sabe o que eu me
lembro do mais do que rendi eu não meu
amigo joão palhaço
sabe o que eu já me dizia olha felipe o
que mais me faz lembrar robert kennedy é
mero leblon
você se lembra daquela cena ep off the
times
o presidente lembra essa cena é mais
aquela canta parabéns pra você para o
presidente e ele sai porque não gostava
dessa cena ele se pensa bem felipe
parabéns pra você as pessoas já estão
aplaudindo e precisa levantar que já tá
todo mundo de pé
é isso que eu quero ser na vida eu quero
ser palhaço primeiro irmão cantar rap
booth pra mim de novo mesmo erro a gente
que a recompensa antes da caminhada e na
caminhada que está a recompensa
isso é que estão vendo é uma foto deste
que vos fala o coquinho feliz eu acho
que vocês podem reparar com as crianças
da favela do alemão no rio de janeiro
essas crianças também o lançamento de um
livro que eu fiz pra eles em 2012 eo
lançamento foi na biblioteca nacional
aquela essas crianças nunca tinham visto
um palácio tão grande quanto à
biblioteca nacional
eu fiz um livro hoje a renda foi
revertida para uma biblioteca itinerante
que seria construída no morro do alemão
para que essas crianças pudessem ler só
que o livro foi um grande fracasso a
gente não teve dinheiro para construir
biblioteca mas essa foto está aí então
fica uma lição do fracasso mesmo nos
maiores fracassos você tem momentos de
sucesso esse é o meu momento de sucesso
essa foto com essas
essa alegria é o que eu falei para
sempre
eu nunca vou esquecer e toda vez que eu
vou morro do alemão subiu o morro do
alemão e lei para essas crianças
eu tenho esses mesmos sorrisos e eles me
satisfazem apesar do meu fracasso e do
fracasso do nosso projeto com um livro
que não rendeu a biblioteca itinerante
para eles há momentos de sucesso os
maiores fracassos
isso aí que vocês estão vendo um
documentário que o lançou no passado
chama se essa vida não fosse minha é um
documentário sobre uma comunidade a vila
autódromo fica ao lado do parque
olímpico do rio de janeiro e todos nós
fazemos festas por causa da limpeza do
rio mas esquecemos das milhares de
pessoas que estão sendo expulsos de suas
casas na cidade para que os jogos
olímpicos aconteça essa comunidade fica
bem ao lado do parque tinha 583 famílias
elas foram expulsas para que se fizessem
os jogos olímpicos será que isso é o
censo será que o fracasso de pessoas que
estão abandonando o lugar onde moram há
40 anos que estão sendo expulsas pelo
prefeito vai causar o sucesso dos jogos
de milhões de pessoas
bilhões de pessoas que vão assistir pelo
mundo não haveria outra alternativa um
poderia ter um legado social deixando
essas pessoas ali eu fiz esse filme
dirigir esse filme
financiei o filme chamei três amigos
para fazerem comigo diretor de
fotografia som e edição
a gente foi a china com esse filme e se
não for festivais na europa a e pequim
venceu festival mas não passou em lugar
nenhum aqui no brasil foi um grande
fracasso em conseguir mobilizar nenhuma
parte da sociedade essas pessoas estão
prestes a ser expulsas das 583 famílias
530 já saíram de lá o poder público o
prefeito massacram a parte pobre da
população do rio enquanto o país e um
mundo festeja uma olimpíada e seu
sucesso ou fracasso
essas são as pessoas eu fracassei com
essas pessoas são os moradores da vila
autódromo são os moradores que estão no
filme essa vida não fosse minha
cada um desses moradores eu olho pra
eles e olha para as famílias deles e me
olha no espelho percebo felipe pena por
ser um fracasso
você não conseguiu ajudar essas pessoas
com filme
mesmo que ele tenha passado no mundo
inteiro essas pessoas continuam sofrendo
o mesmo problema
as pessoas continuam passando pela mesma
ditadura do poder público do rio de
janeiro que as expulsa em nome de uma
olimpíada
se você fosse um atleta olímpico acha
que isso valeria a pena
será que vale a pena ter uma medalha no
peito à custa do sofrimento de pessoas
como vocês estão vendo como faço sempre
essa pergunta e se você não vê na tela e
é um foi diretor da quarta maior
emissora do país
sou eu o baiano parece claro que eu
fracassei como diretor da tv globo sabe
quanto tempo ficou no cargo cinco meses
cinco meses eu eo ministro da educação
lembrando agora para a educadora
ministro janeiro e ficou cinco meses
onde é que nós erramos ministro me diga
eu posso dizer
acho que erramos na política porque a
gente agora que temos uma política muito
a definir a estrada pela corrupção
nós acreditamos que a política não vale
a pena mas ela vale sim
e se você não encontrar em quem votar
você mesmo deve se candidatar à política
não significa só voto político só num
simples o brasília política significa
falar com as pessoas no meu cargo de
diretor de análise de conteúdo e devia
dizer aos novelista da tv globo onde
eles haviam errado
só que eu fazer isso com relatórios
altamente técnicos e fez um pós
doutorado na sorbonne
achava que tinha conhecimento técnico
para fazer isso mas eu tinha que fazer
mais o que conversar
eu não conversei e por isso deixei de
ser diretor em cinco meses foi derrubado
com a maior facilidade eu eo ministro é
fácil derrubar quando você não sabe
fazer política faça um político é
preciso fazer sucesso fracasso também
dependem disso também foi roteirista da
tv globo durante três anos
apresentei sinopse de uma novela das
sete apresentei 10 projetos de seriados
sabe quando furou a 0
nenhum deles foram à mas aí vem outra
lição do fracasso tudo pra cá sempre
alguma coisa no meu seio pra fazer esse
livro vocês estão vendo eu coloquei o
roteiro a sinopse da novela das sete e
mais um seriado de terror e um seriado a
policial e aí os meus alunos podem se
aproveitar disso entender onde foi que
eu
porque na margem de cada roteiro tem as
observações das pessoas que criticam que
me criticaram e porque os roteiros não
foram lá é que os alunos podem aprender
com os meus erros
então os meus fracassos na tv está
disponível para todos vocês que queiram
ser roteiristas por exemplo o queiram
trabalhar numa emissora de televisão
por último essa foto aí essa foto é dos
moradores da vila autódromo assistindo
ao filme lá na igreja da comunidade
junto com alguns repórteres da imprensa
internacional que o trouxe para que ele
se sentisse um drama daquela comunidade
e hoje alguns órgãos da imprensa
nacional já falam daquela comunidade
e aqui vai a minha última a lembrança
para vocês não sei se vocês conhecem a
fábula dos cotovelos mas na minha
opinião é ela que define a diferença
entre o sucesso eo fracasso a favor dos
cotovelos é a seguinte existe um
jornalista que queria conhecer o céu eo
inferno
no primeiro ele foi um inferno ele pediu
licença ao assessor de imprensa do diabo
e disse olha posso conhecer o inferno
falou bem fininho entrou por um portão e
de fogo passou à direita e olhou para as
pessoas do meio do inferno e reparou que
as pessoas no inferno
eram todas felizes todas sorrindo e
ninguém trabalhava era uma maravilha no
inferno
só que ele não mais de perto daquelas
pessoas felizes rindo e se divertindo e
reparou que elas tinham os cotovelos
invertidos e por terem os cotovelos
divertidos elas acabam morrendo de fome
porque não conseguiram trazer comida até
a boca então ele saiu correndo de lá
saiu correndo quero ficar aqui não quero
morrer de fome e de cooperação pedro
falou pedro posso eu quero conhecer o
céu foi subiu passou por 11 um portão de
nuvens à direita entrou no céu quando
ele chega no céu ele repara que é o
mesmo tipo de pessoa as pessoas também
estão todos felizes
ninguém trabalha todo mundo só se
diverte todo mundo só aí tá todo mundo
só contando piada que ele vai fazer é
olhar para os cotovelos a ele olha os
contras as pessoas reparam que as
pessoas também têm os cotovelos
invertidos
a única diferença é que no céu as
pessoas não morrem de fome porque uma
leva a comida até a boca do outro
é isso que aprenderam os moradores da
vila autódromo que juntos eles são
fortes e que só a solidariedade funciona
hoje 57 famílias ainda resistem com os
cotovelos invertidos dando comida um na
boca do outro e eu junto com eles
tentando essa missão e solidariedade
fracassei com um filme pra cá sei com os
livros fracassem no cinema pra casa e na
tv globo
após fracassar com eles mas vou
fracassar junto só existe track' aço
a desunião na união o fracasso se torna
um sucesso ainda que você fracasse
então tudo que desejo a vocês e que
vocês tenham solidariedade em que os
cotovelos invertido de vocês se juntem
que vocês sejam aplaudidos de pé durante
dez minutos durante dez segundos durante
o tempo que foi de suas vidas desde que
as vidas vocês sejam dedicadas ao
momento de solidariedade
muito obrigado
trinta segundos valeu meu dia